my brothers and sisters there is a authentic Hadith in
wherein the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam is marveling from different angles at the amazing Trust the
prophets all had in Allah azzawajal
so he says in this Hadith
Ibrahim
we would doubt God before Ibrahim and of course he would never doubt God which means
Ibrahim alaihissalam always trusted God never doubted him in other words don't misread that Ayah about
oh Allah show me how you give life to the dead he tells them take a
bird and chop it up put it on separate mountains he wanted to increase his trust
but he had great trust he wanted another level that people don't have it's beyond human
reach for the most part
and so he's saying he never doubted he always had Supreme trust if he would have
doubted we would have doubted first then in that same Hadith he goes on to say
set aside for loot Prophet lot for he used to certainly seek strength in the strongest
corner
with the strongest support pillar which is Allah azzawajal meaning don't misread that story of prophet
in the Quran and he said I wish I had a bigger family
in other words yes he wished he had in front of his eyes people that could
help him from his guests being abducted by those criminals that wanted to practice indecency with
them right against their will he's saying he said that but his heart never saw but
Allah
he used to always keep his trust in Allah firm he didn't lose hope in Allah
and wish his families could sort of compensate no then the third statement he said in
the same Hadith he says
and me if I would have remained in prison for as long as Joseph remained in
prison I would have responded to the caller you know when when Joseph was framed and
thrown in prison and then they said to him the king wants to meet you you're
really good at this dream interpretation thing he said no he had such trust in Allah
that Allah would not just give him his freedom but he would Restore for him his
reputation with the people clear my name first and so all these three are trust and
these are so important because we all need it whether it's like Ibrahim alaihissalam trusting God
and not giving in to The Whispers that could be doubts later on not with Ibrahim
or whether it's like your security is under threat but you never waver your eyes see
Allah and you trust him throughout whatever security threat services in your life your safety or
whether you're like Yusuf your your reputation your respectability people's opinion of you is threatened you
put your trust in Allah and we all need to grow that trust because these things
are unavoidable the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam told us that there is no uncertainty about it
adversity challenges in life are certain that part you can be certain about it's uncertainty in
terms of is it going to be in my job or is it going to be
in terms of my children or is it going to be in terms of like a
marital challenge or is it going to be an income challenge we don't know but you
need to know that it will be there and hence we all are in deep need
of growing and regrowing our trust in Allah you see the believer is different he does
not think that life will get easier
but he believes that through trusting Allah he can get stronger through true and proper tawakul
Reliance on him Supreme trust in God you can arm her up for whatever life throws
at you whatever tomorrow brings per se for life's blows you can handle them because you
know that Allah said
whoever puts their true trust in Allah truly trusts him Allah will be enough you know
that you can be that person that when the world around you has become so fragile
that they have a meltdown from being pricked by a thorn you can have an avalanche
of hardships in your life and you could just take it in stride
the great scholar though he says you need to keep something in mind to grow your
tawaku you will never have an airtight system you know like a true tawakul that doesn't
fail you true trust and God doesn't fail you without four components and I want you
to remember them today he says the first of them is to have deep knowledge of
Allah his names his attributes his Perfection or else how else are you going to trust
him you know I would trust the child you know with
my pen
I would need an adult to trust them with my car how do I trust someone
with my existence
unless I know them deeply their credibility is clear to me that's why Allah azzawajal says
you got to remember that only belonging to Allah is the Unseen don't have misplaced confidence
in yourself even or in others excessive confidence nobody knows the Unseen nobody can tell you
what's going to happen five seconds from now so don't trust anybody the way you trust
him belonging to Allah is the Unseen in the skies and the Earth
and all matters go back to him he's the ultimate decider who
since that's the case then devote your life to him and put your trust in him
notice how because he's the knower of the Unseen because he is the one that says
to a thing be and it is then we devote and we trust what's
you know speaking of B and it is this is of what feeds your your knowledge
of God Hadith about him we have so much the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said there
used to be a man among the people before you who on his deathbed he gathers
his children and says listen what kind of father was I to you they said you
were the best dad ever he said I need to admit something to you I've never
done any good in my life
for either enemy so once I die you need to take my body and you need
to burn it
and when it is a cold I want you to shatter it cremate me turn me
into ashes and then once I'm ashes you wait until it is a windy day and
then Take Me Out To The Shore and throw some of me to the wind and
some of me in the ocean because if Allah is able look he even doubted Allah's
ability but he will still get forgiven
if Allah is able to grab a hold of me he will punish me in a
way that he's never punished anyone he knows he deserves it and he made each of
his children promise or else he would disown them that they would do this and they
didn't
and after they did this whole long thing right
obviously the Hadith is fast forwarding for us the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam says to us
meaning about the day of judgment and then Allah says be Kun
all of a sudden he's a man standing again just like that and then Allah says
to him o my servant
what drove you to do all this oh long story why he said I was afraid
of you Allah
it wasn't long before Allah enveloped him in his Mercy other reports of this Hadith indicate
that this is actually the the first chapter of that story we know from the Hereafter
and the other Hadith about the last man to exit the Hellfire the last man to
enter Paradise
but look be and it is so that is someone that I can trust I can
relegate I can submit to regarding the unknowns of life but I need to say it
is not just knowledge about him in the theoretical the other way you cultivate this first
pillar deep knowledge of Allah is by devoting yourself to him or else all the facts
in the world won't matter a part of not you know deactivating not rendering pointless for
you that knowledge of Allah is you closing the gap between your knowledge and your actions
it's not fully possible but exerting yourself the more you devote yourself to him the More
Alive these realities that you read about in the Quran and sunnar so that's the first
pillar deep knowledge of Allah through Revelation and through devotion the second pillar
of proper Reliance in Allah is to have solid conviction in Destiny
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said to us
if any one of you were to spend Mount have you ever seen mount no one
has ever done this if you were to spend mounted in Gold it would not be
accepted of you until you believe in qadar until you believe in destiny
to the degree that you are sure that what hit you wasn't going to miss you
and what missed you was not going to hit you
and if you are to die believing anything else Allah will admit you to the fire
think about that Allah is obligating you even with this heavy language to armor yourself up
with the reality that it's all in Allah's hands I'm making it a must on you
to not believe a lie you must believe that everything is in his hands
believe in destiny be sure about it this is the foundation of our faith and you
need to also know that shaytan targets this Foundation this is sort of what he strikes
at
the Quran tells you this that
is
shaytan threatens you with poverty you're going to go broke and so then he instructs you
with indecency because you're afraid of going broke then he's going to tell you now cut
Corners now be unethical or the other Ayah says that he said to Adam
shall I direct you to a tree of what of everlasting life the tree of Eternity
and a kingdom that never perishes so he's constantly telling you you need this you're going
to be in trouble you're going to die soon you're going to go broke soon and
so shaitaan he targets these things on purpose
and so Allah's Revelation comes targeting these things to restore your conviction that your life is
in his hands Don't Panic that your Provisions are in his hands no one can be
able to take them away from you
you need to know that if you would have stayed home those who were destined to
die at that battle would have went out to meet their death anyway they would have
went out to use the bathroom went out for a trade or a business it was
destined to die here so don't say oh man I don't want to do the right
thing or else my life will be shortened or my finances will be restricted don't ever
accept that be sure of what Allah is telling you or the other Ayan Hadid on
this point when Allah says no Calamity befalls you on Earth or in the heavens except
that it's recorded in a book before it happens
why is Allah telling you this he says so you don't grieve too much on what
you because of what you missed out on
and you don't get too delusional about the good things that come your way it's all
written it's all a test comes in different shapes sizes colors and flavors but it's all
just predestined all predetermined this is ABC's Islam
you know that is why that famous Imam I often recall when the the ruler of
his time said to him your life is in my hands fear me shut your mouth
he said to him
if I actually believe that at my destiny and my life was in your hands it
wouldn't have worshiped anybody but you right
and so when you fold it is a sign that your knowledge of God is not
deep enough our belief in Destiny has wavered
when you cut corners and try to get married the haramue when you cut Corners just
try to get a raise or a promotion or more income the haramue
that means you believe you can circumvent the system right the trust of Allah needs to
be grown regrown at that point so we said deep knowledge of Allah and we said
firm conviction in his Destiny
and that is reflected by us beautifying our requests as the Hadith says the third and
fourth are very simple
the third of them is that you seek the means that are available to you
meaning everything is destined everything is Allah's will but he gave you enough of agency enough
of a will a choice enough of it at least to be held responsible for your
actions and you see this the prophet when he went to war he wore armor didn't
he when he was fasting and it became too hot he spilled cold water on his
head didn't he when he got sick he sought out doctors and Medicine didn't he
one time they told him that a bunch of men were sitting in the Masjid saying
we put our full trust in God
he said these people have never opened the Quran in their life
I'm paraphrasing
he says they have never smelled knowledge forget touch it he said they've never smelled knowledge
he said didn't they hear Allah saying to Maryam
our mother Mary the mother of Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
Shake towards you the trunk of the palm tree ripe edible dates will fall on you
you know men can't bring dates from a palm tree like this you gotta go up
climb and get it so how can a woman right after the pain of Labor do
it why did Allah tell her that to show us that you still got to do
your part you still gotta try you still have to reach
that's why the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he said if you were to trust Allah the
way he deserves to be trusted trust Allah fully and properly he would provide for you
the way he provides for the birds
the birds are trying but they're not experts they're sort of trying randomly but they come
home every day with a full stomach for the most part likewise you want to try
but don't be overconfident in your effort in your energy in your expertise in your attempt
seek the means though
deep knowledge of Allah solid conviction unwavering Faith about Destiny seeking the available means number fourth
as we just said the fourth one is not relying on those means those means are
effective by Allah's permission you know when they ask the prophet saws should we use medicine
one time he said
medicine is from what Allah distance meaning if he destineds for you to find it available
you'll find it available and if he destins for you to hit the spot for you
it will work right you still gotta go for it but know that it's from Allah
when you go for it I was once told about a man and I may have
shared this with you before that used to throw his pill on the ground before taking
it
he wasn't crazy he was just trying to remind himself that the doctors are lying the
doctors are short-sighted the doctors that don't believe in Allah are telling him your life depends
on this he's saying it can't even help itself right I throw it on the ground
it's powerless so if it's gonna help me it's going to help me by Allah's permission
the same way a knife Cuts you're supposed to use knives to cut something right
but he can stop it from cutting the way he stopped it with Ibrahim a fire
burns it can burn it has the quality of burning but it can cause it to
not burn the same way he did with Ibrahim
and so that is that heart never wavering true Reliance on Allah means Reliance of the
heart while still engaging the reality and I'll share with you two things in this next
in this last minute that those four components means that you have proper tawakul once proper
telekul is accomplished it doesn't mean you're going to get the outcome you want all the
time sometimes Allah will withhold it from you for a better outcome
right or wrong that's important to remember
secondly says don't you dare get cheated for your tawakul he said what does it mean
some people do tell wrong we've already discussed that some people do it right but they
sell themselves short like I'm gonna trust Allah correctly for a job and a wife and
a child and some respect and he goes use tawakul in your Deen Above All Else
Allah can get you past that deadlock can get you to grow Beyond everyone in your
generation can get you to be a reason for the direction of the ummah to accelerate
in positive ways at positive
rates as well you sawakul for your Deen and Allah will take care of your worldly
stay and your religious commitment may we be people who supremely trust in Allah properly and
for the most important objectives of Our Lives May Allah make us of those who trust
before and after the outcome may we be of those confident in him stepping into tomorrow
and the Unseen and may we be of those who assume the best of him if
he decides other than what we wish for and what we dream about Allah I mean
thank you